I might be too excited hello my name is
Grace helic it's 10: a.m. and welcome to
I'd like to do something silly and
stupid it's Halloween I have breast
cancer I'm not doing anything I'm not
going anywhere but I did want to
participate in some capacity I'm already
tired cuz I'm so excited last minute I
had an idea for an incredibly stupid
Halloween costume so I'm going to try to
make it this Halloween I'm sure you've
seen plenty of Barbies plenty of weird
Barbies plenty of tail Swift and Travis
Kelsey I'm going to be one of the alien
bodies that the Mexican Government
exposed a few months ago that are likely
very fake alien bodies isn't that cute
this is an ambitious costume I think the
worst I do at this perhaps the better
the final result will be I have a lot of
Halloween makeup and just an endless
well of determination for stupidity it's
my purpose that's my gift I bought a
bunch of ball caps to try try and make
this costume work and I don't think
they're going to work so I have a
different idea for the head shape that
we'll get into later this costume speaks
to me on a lot of levels lately I been
feeling like a crusty Dusty shriveled up
little alien body this is how I feel I
look when I lay on the couch for days at
a time after infusion days and I too
often feel not real so me and this
little Sandy alien body one in the same
you could say I have a couple reference
photos that I'm going to try to recreate
but this is oh I like couldn't sleep
like last night because I was so excited
to try and do this and I think I'm
either going to do this very well or I'm
going to do this very not well and
either of those outcomes I think will be
good I went on Amazon and I bought like
a nude turtleneck and yesterday I
painted it you know you see what we're
going for here I'm going to put this on
cuz I won't be able to put this on after
I do my makeup and I only painted the
front because we're literally quite
literally doing this for the gram oh I
haven't put deodorant on I'm going to
put deodorant on cuz I will for sure
sweat through the little alien pities
okay yeah you're kind of getting the
image right
you're oh this is so dumb I've never
felt more aligned with my purpose don't
worry I will be making another video to
update you on the breast cancer progress
thoughts and feelings this last week was
but this is what we're doing today
forgive a bit of my bald spots the cold
capping doesn't work 100% oh my God oh
my God okay I just want to do a really
decent job my expectations for
myself are high do I start with the
light colors and then put dark colors on
top I watched an entire season of glow
up lay on the couch last week did I
learn nothing ding dong this is going to
be a ding dong I'll tell you what it's
going to give off the sound that I've
been hit in the head with a hammer maybe
I'll use this stuff as the base oh this
might be too white we're going to blend
it a
lot I guess we'll just cover the whole
face in a little bit of this do I let
this dry and my crusty lips actually
really play into this now I need to get
it more like gray we're
blending I think I need darker darker
gray got to like shape around the eye
okay getting a little bit of face shape
There Eyes sort of like sort of okay
that's oh my God is this offensive is
this offensive I don't think it is
aliens might find it offensive I guess
aliens texting me about wanting to come
inside right now hold on give me another
20 minutes I had dreams of this being
excellent is is this even close at this
point do that look like the alien face
that working sort of sort of it's like
sand on top more close to my Foundation
color maybe I should go get my old
Foundation oh go it's right here I'll
use my old foundation brush cuz this
needs to be thrown away anyway oh my God
up cycling this might be working we're
going to keep blending and mixing and
blending and mixing until I ultimately
hate it and then I bring it back to
Center I was going to try and get sand
and like throw it on me
but try find your mouth goes earier
doing H more rounded not cat eye round
oval round oval not cat eye obviously
think that's a little bit better we
don't want to look like an idiot I think
we're getting very close I don't want to
do too much I don't want
to now's the right time to say I'm not a
professional makeup artist right I know
go you're wanting your caretaker is very
busy I think I think the makeup's in a
place that I'm okay with now let me
explain to you how I do the head like I
said I originally wanted and wish that I
had Bal cap skills I do not I'm going to
put my hair up in this thing I have just
a gray beanie that I filled with a wig
and another beanie to give it that shape
and I'm going to do I mean yes I wish it
was a BAL capat but I think you'll get
the point
across that's pretty good right that's
pretty good just doing a little I think
that's pretty good okay now I'm going to
invite Elliot in this makeup is fading
fast okay my other camera broke but
Elliot's going to come inside and help
me set up for an
Instagram close enough you know let's
see if we can get his reaction it's me
hi
baby what do you think it's really
really
good God that's horrible you're tough to
look at thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you
okay we successfully took some photos I
think thanks for watching happy
Halloween